Donald I have to ask you something last
time you're on the show you were talking
about how your wife Casey was gonna give
birth at any minute but that you still
decided to honor your commitment to come
on the show yes because I love you so
much right and first things first right
you know Conan and then baby's birth of
Mariah yeah yes and your wife was cool
with you making the decision to to come
on the talk show absolutely she was like
you have to be on Conan okay but here's
the thing she gave birth that day she
did I made it back in time I got it back
in time I know someone in the audience
gasped audibly you monster
no but you did you you you left the
studio you rushed to the heart of the
hospital she had the baby and it was
wonderful it was great it was great now
there's Rocco the 16 months 16 months
we're gonna have our second child now
and the baby will be here in April why
you could applaud now nobody did it now
the audience is sort of like I think
ones enough
she's not are you sure that's the right
thing yeah so does your white cuz you
talked you talked quite a bit about
about Casey your wife last time you were
on the show does she mind when you talk
about her she does not like it at all
yeah but she you know she's so beautiful
she's so wonderful and you know I feel
like I should talk about her all the
time and I've made the mistake a couple
of times I'm going on
you know interviews and and saying
really I guess things I I guess she said
that I shouldn't have said right uh you
know this is a different pregnancy for
her and so she's changing a lot now and
there are things about her that are
different and you go into detail about
chimes you know and she's like keep my
name out your mouth do not discuss me
very intimate personal things when a
woman is feeling and she's pregnant and
you're talking about it I think it's
wonderful you know and I mean she's
growing a human inside of her yeah and
you know she's you know sometimes your
areola get dark they get real right like
they were pink now they're purple that's
too much just tricked you into getting
again that's the beauty of what we're
doing right now right now she's gotta
kill me so I saw this paparazzi photo of
you yes
like I said things change things change
okay well how do you think has your wife
feel about this paparazzi shot of you
handling her backside like that I'd like
to say she loves it and you can't say
like I got caught by the paparazzi
accidentally cuz look you are looking
right check this out
yeah okay are you gonna get me killed
yeah yeah that's what I do all right I'm
here to end marriages
you